a libertarian businessman decided he can
build a better school the bad ideas that
were developed within the public school
system has to be thrown out for
significantly less money I just want an
unlimited budget so therefore they say
business doesn't apply education is a
business instead of trying to reform the
public schools from within he's
providing a way out there's two ways you
can approach life voice or exit is a
prime mover is exit probability is the
owner of the nation's leading
manufacturer of commercial kitchen
ventilation system he built captive air
from scratch now it has factories in six
state and revenues last year of four
hundred million dollars so what does
fabricating stove hoods and cooling
systems have in common with turning out
successful people more than you might
think
bloody got interested in education when
he deserved that many hires at captain
air lack the basic math and science
skills to thrive on the job
she became co-chair of its statewide
Education Commission and met with North
Carolina officials the voices concerns
and they were happy to discuss all these
ideas that work available in any of them
the last straw was 1997 when Lettie ran
for a seat on local school board and law
which turned out to be a great blessing
because immediately thereafter I filed a
charter for Chronicle Academy today
Franklin Academy is the largest charter
school in North Carolina and the waiting
list to get in has about four students
vying for every one kindergarten spot so
the markets overwhelmingly signaling
we're not happy with the public school
system but even charters are controlled
by the state which ludie says constrains
innovation so he decided to take a more
radical step which he called aggregate
what is voice voice as you go to vote
you express an opinion exit is for
somebody comes up an entirely new idea
they live happy
industry and they get amazing results so
in 2007 he created a nonprofit network
called bailey's academy the goal was to
make private education so affordable
that many more families have the option
of leaving the public system behind to
give a sense about inexpensive it is to
attend saving compared it to Ravens crop
in elite private school in the Raleigh
area where tuition is about twenty
thousand dollars per year North
Carolina's public schools spend about 90
300 dollars per pupil at Bayley's
average tuition is $5,500
that's an event that many middle-class
families can afford so how does Daly's
do it certainly part of the equation is
that it doesn't serve kids with severe
learning disabilities or expensive to
educate but another major factor is
infrastructure the town of Roseville
North Carolina has been seventy six
million dollars on this public school in
2013 two and a half miles away in a year
later
Bailey's opened in nine million dollar
high school so much smaller on a per
pupil basis the building cost half as
much if you look at a modern-day public
school you see the tennis court in the
sports field to me they look more like a
Sports Complex that by the way we also
build a school in the back of the lot
all we need our classrooms some
facilities for recreation and play but
that's it
another savings is on personnel there's
no cafeteria and there's no cafeteria
staff no school buses and that's no
school bus driver a lot of schools
you're going to have an assistant
principal you're going to have a social
worker and got it counselor in a school
nurse and those are not things that you
are going to see it daily how their
brain is the head of a faiis elementary
school
I am the reading coach and I'm the math
code but because we don't have other
things on our plate and we don't have
transportation we don't deal with the
cafeteria and there are lots of other
pieces that are not on a typical
administrators plate that we can make it
work in the public school system every
teacher they have another person working
for the school system so half the people
are not patient somebody also saves
money by hiring fewer actual teachers
the students at Bailey's are groups so
that everyone in the same classroom has
roughly the same command of the material
this way they can all follow a lesson
with less individual attention from the
teacher in North Carolina's public
schools there's about one teacher for
every 15 kids Bailey's is targeting a
teacher to student ratio of 26 to one
most schools consider small class sizes
a benchmark of success
ludie is proud of having large class
sizes because it demonstrates efficiency
in the same way that when captive air
can produce more stove hoods with fewer
employees ultimately that savings get
passed on to customers in business we
look at outcome did we gain sales did we
please our customers schools don't look
at it we have a big building we have
sports they're all inputs
[Music]
another kita cadaveric except is
constant innovation something Letty says
would be possible to replicate either
traditional public schools or charters
I always view charters as a transitional
idea so they're far better than the
public school system because they have
private management they can be put out
of business there's less regulation
however there's still regulation and
what happens over time the bureaucrats
are going to continue to load more
regulation on charters in North Carolina
the majority of the faculty of charter
schools must be state certified which
generally involves taking education
courses and passing a licensure exam you
can have a doctoral degree in
mathematics but you cannot teach in the
k-12 system individuals like myself who
are more libertarian they don't want to
deal with this kind of nonsense and now
we're going to write all the numbers are
coffee you may be gay so if you look at
say Lee's we don't require a licensing
we want to know how good of a teacher
they are but if they have a master's
degree and they're not a great teacher
that we don't consider the message to
read to be very valuable and when a
public school has a mediocre teachers
parents are more likely to be complacent
since they're not directly paying that
person salaries letti says the tuition
bills that family gives families more
skin in the game
anything we pay for we take better care
of the things that we don't pay for
Bailey's enters its tenth year of
operation letting his peon has grand
ambition they're currently 25 new daily
schools in the planning stages that
would extend the network to reach into
Georgia Tennessee and Florida well we
hit 25 then the goal will be 100
and the old educational establishment is
gradually declining and at some point in
time it's going to decline much more
rapidly so one of my goals is to be a
shining example of what can be done so
that others will follow
[Music]